hello everyone in this video we'll talk
about
yellow fungus disease in kovid 19
patients
this yellow fungus disease is now all
over the news headlines so let's
understand
what this yellow fungus disease means
and how dangerous it is
you must be aware of black fungus
disease or mucor mycosis
which can be seen in covid recovered
patients
in past few months there has been
several cases
in the states of gujarat maharashtra
andhra pradesh
for much or my causes if you want to
learn more about mukar makosis
you can get a video by clicking on the i
button
now recently there has been cases
of white fungus and also yellow fungus
now this might be funny right what are
these all white yellow and black
funguses
does these color mean anything or it's
just a misnomer
so in this video we'll learn all the
science behind that
and stay tuned till the end of this
video so right now
if you are watching social media or
reading newspapers
these questions might be in your head
that what are these diseases
how much i should worry and what can i
do to keep myself
safe and the biggest question right now
is where does this fungal infection come
from because they were not known
before how our immune system can fight
against
this fungus if we have a healthy immune
system in the first place
and what is the relationship between
kovid infection and
all these fungal infections is there any
relation at all now there are many
countries who are worsely affected
by kovid 19 but india is one of the
country
which is reporting high number of kovid
associated
fungal or secondary infection cases
we have to understand why india is the
hot spot and not any other western
countries
so all of these things would be
discussed in this video
now let me tell you that several species
of mucor
and rhizopus are known as
muco i mean known to cause mucour
mycosis
so called black fungal disease then
several species of aspergillus and
candida
leads to aspergillosis or candidiasis
and these kind of infections are
actually known as white fungus infection
lastly there is a rare species of fungus
generally found in reptiles whose name
is pretty difficult and it's pronounced
as
nanny zeophysis and paren and
nesiophysis
so these fungal species cause
yellow fungal disease now only one
yellow fungal disease
case has been reported so far in india
so
you might not worry so much about it but
let's learn more about this thing
so this yellow fungus does not look
yellow at all under the microscope
this is how a yellow fungus should look
like and i have provided the source in
this video
now this yellow fungal disease causes
yellow blemishes on the skin of iguana
and many other lizards
and from that aspect it might be
named as yellow fungus let's talk about
the symptoms
which includes reduced appetite lethargy
and headache now these symptoms are
pretty common in many diseases
so if you have these symptoms that
doesn't mean that you you would
have yellow fungal disease so consulting
your ent
or your general physician would be a
good idea in that
case now let's talk about some
white funguses again these white
funguses is also a misnomer generally
these white funguses
are nothing but aspergillus and candida
so
aspergillus fumigators or aspergillus
[ __ ]
are the key species which are
responsible for aspergillosis or white
fungus infection
now there are several type of
aspergillosis such as
allergic bronchopulmonary aspergillosis
or chronic pulmonary aspergillosis
all of these affects the lungs when
there could be
invasive or systemic aspartylosis in
that case
our brain can be affected as well
so it's pretty deadly the question is
where does these fungus come from or
them all the mucour mycosis species come
from
moist soil decaying organic matter
animal dung
from these places and these are also the
source
for white funguses such as all these
aspergillus or candida
so we right now know that what are the
sources and where we can generally find
these funguses
now there is an important point these
fungal diseases
are not really harmful to general people
and that is why we didn't knew about
these funguses for so long right
but problem comes when you are
immunocompromised
then these funguses are really deadly
for you
now apart from covid patients these kind
of fungal infect infections are
previously reported in patients
who has undergone organ transplantation
or stem cell transplantation
a person who is taking drugs a person
who is diabetic and undergoing diabetic
ketosis
acidosis or a person who is taking
chemotherapy
and having a cancer so all of these
category of people are more susceptible
towards these kind of secondary fungal
infections
covid patients who have recovered are
most likely
immunocompromised because steroids are
given to them
to prevent the interleukin storm now
that has taken serious toll on their
immune system
even if they have recovered from the
virus but their immune system is
extremely weak but the good part about
these mycosis
infections are they're not contiguous
like covid19 so if
even if you are in near vicinity of a
person who is infected with mucormicosis
or any other fungal type
you are not likely to get it
as per medication antifungal drugs could
be used
for treatment early detection can also
lead to surgical removal of that
infested tissue
now if the detection is late then then
this particular infection could be
prevented deadly as well
now let's talk about why india is the
hot spot for kovid 19 associated fungal
infection not
why not any other country like usa or
like let's say canada
the biggest reason is climate
hygiene and many other aspects so let's
discuss them one by one
now the hospitals are overwhelmed during
second wave of kovid in india
and there was a huge scarcity of oxygen
now kovid patients need oxygen support
for
their survival now in that case many of
the cases the doctor had
no other option to give the patients
industry-grade oxygen cylinder
medical grade oxygen cylinder are pure
and the oxygen is tested to be safe for
patients
but these kind of testing and quality
control is not done for
industry grid so there could be problems
associated with these cylinders
now instead of losing the patient that
might be a good decision to use these
things
but that might have increased the
chances of secondary fungal infections
because these unsterilized cylinders
might have fungal spores inside them
second point is the oxygen delivery
system
so from the oxygen cylinder the oxygen
bubbles through
a chamber known as humidifier and then
through a tubing it reaches
the patient this humidifier is
key part of this delivery system because
you need to give
moist oxygen now water
is one of the region where fungus can
grow
so if sterilized water is not used
then there is a huge chance that fungus
might grow in this water
in case of these tubing the if the
tubing material is not cleaned properly
or the tubing is not
not recycled or changed
then that can also increase the risk of
fungal infections now apart from that
there are many other reason
let's say a kovid recovered individual
has to go to his office in this
scorching
heat now in the summer time when the
temperature is
almost as high as 35 degree centigrade
to 40 degree centigrade
there would be a huge humidity and
perspiration
now this humid situation and this
temperature
is the optimal situation for fungal
growth
that is why if you inspect the mask we
might see
fungal growth in this mask now
we might ask that what we can do for our
own safety
so one kind of advice is to
change the mask very frequently
so if you change the mask frequently the
risk that you would inhale the fungal
spores would really decrease
now apart from these things there are a
few other important points
washing the mask drying the mask and
keeping the mask
safely in a sterilized packet all of
these things are really
important hygiene that we should follow
now the problem in india is like you
keep the mask here and there let's say
you put the mask on
a humid place or let's say a moldy place
so all the spores of the fungus get in
or are now stuck in the mask and next
time when you inhale
all of those those pores goes inside
your respiratory system which might lead
to several
complications now we have to understand
these kind of
effects i mean these kind of risks are
always there and people need to be
educated about them
now let's think about a farmer
because many cases people don't have
choice
this farmer was infected with kovid 19
and now he is recovered and he has to go
back to the field for his own job
now while he is doing or while he is
performing any farming related activity
he might encounter animal dung
or moist soil etc right which are
breeding ground for funguses
and that is why just after kovid he is
more susceptible
towards fungal infection now we learn
that
how fungal infections can spread now the
biggest question is can our immune
system
fight against these funk funguses yes
the answer is right so
we have two branches of immune system
inet and adaptive immune system
both innate and adaptive immune system
components
can fight fungal infection one such
component
is neutrophil which is a component of
our blood
and their phagocytic activity really
helps
to prevent fungal infections or
it can fight against fungal infections
now how does our body know
that a fungus has entered or invaded our
territory
now these fungus cell walls they have
specific signature of sugar molecules
such as glycans mannons etc and that can
be
detected by dedicated cell type of our
immune system and these are known as
pathogen-associated molecular patterns
so that could be detected by specific
receptors that is how our body
know that we are affected by a fungal
infection
immediately there would be responses
such as complement fixation
so this complement fixation can degrade
the fungus
now apart from these responses th1 which
is a
t helper cell subtype can also
fight back fungal infections t
helper one cell secretes a specific
molecule known as
interferon gamma which is proven to be
pretty effective
to activate macrophages now macrophages
are scavenger cells
which can scavenge and engulf
all these pathogens such as funguses or
bacteria whoever come in their way
so this strong macrophage in activation
via th oneself is one of the defense
response apart from that
one particular subtype of t helper cell
is known as th17 cell
which are crucial for defense against
fungal infection so
il-17 or interleukin-17 is a key
molecule
which gives us this particular
protection and this is secreted by
th17 cell now th17 cells
are generated when naive t cells are
activated
in presence of interleukin 6 or tgf beta
right but in case of covid patient the
biggest problem is interleukin
storm and that is why specific
medication is provided to prevent the
interleukin storm
once we prevent the interleukin storm
the th17 cells which are crucial for
fungal infection or crucial for defense
against fungal infection
they are just compromised and that is
why
we are more susceptible towards a fungal
disease
now let's try to understand
that whether these fungal diseases are
very new or they existed for quite a
long time
it turns out if you look for case
histories
in hiv patients these kind of fungal
infections were reported previously
now at this situation what we can tell
that
hygiene in hospital settings need to be
improvised
and hospital premises should be
sanitized regularly such there
such that all the germs and other
pathogens could be
uh could be eliminated
when it is your personal hygiene you
should wash your hands you should
wear clean clothes as much as possible
and also
cleaning your household disinfecting
surfaces is
crucial now after watching this long
video you might be thinking that
funguses are like devils but let me tell
you out of
millions of species of fungus only 400
are harmful agents many fungus we eat
right and they are pretty delicious so
don't
be aversed of funguses but stay safe in
this pandemic time
with that i'll finish my video if you
like this video give it a big thumbs up
don't forget to like share and subscribe
and you can support my channel on
patreon and thanks for listening